and i think i mentioned levees us before
we say that cooking the process by which
you know nature is transformed into
culture and European civilization you
know tetany you can go back and anything
can be filtered through the food itself
I mean anthropology history sociology
even politic you know I mean you have
political decision like you're the the
tax on like a bell in France in the 17th
century which with a tax on salt though
the political decision would decide
where the food goals or other food is
going to be consumed or the embargo of
color in the 70s again the grand
pooh-bah go again certain country of
Europe this political decision as we see
in Africa now another part of the world
will determine where the food goes would
die a new style and would die and leave
you know so those are whether its
political religion you know food can be
the Bible is an enormous suits for for
food or for for history of food if you
want you know so whether it's a theology
there is no no part of social science
which cannot be really filtered through
food and to a certain extent now it
become a subject which is more not only
relevant but more respected I mean at
Boston University we are offering now a
master of Liberal up with a
concentration in gastronomy I mean that
would have been totally unthinkable 23
years ago in even less than that when i
came to america and i work at the patio
was considered the greatest French
restaurant here I was part of local 89
and local 89 with a dishwasher the shape
to cook to everyone within the same
basket there was no difference and at
that point you know I have to say that
after how
after the private you I work for Howard
Johnson I work with a lot of black
people black share behind the soul
that's what I were the most into the
kitchen and now that the cooking had
exploded and not become very glamorous
and inspired and even genius like you
know then you for some reason and I
think it's a lust for the country don't
have many black who are into cooking now
a couple you know but don't marry but
many young American chef are in that
business now which I say years ago they
would not even that was considered a low
uninspired type of job which now it's
exactly the opposite so we have the
peregrination of the chef it's quite
interesting because something happened
in the same where in the 17th 18th
century in France in fact they were the
book written by mano in the first half
of the 18th century which is called a
nouvelle cuisine française to the new
French cooking so you see the double
cuisine which erupted here in the 70s
was already existing in the in the 18th
century when it went down and up
quitting water than attacks again during
during at the end of the 19th century at
the time of the belly pub then it went
down and up again so it's an interesting
to look at this story of cooking the
technology certainly has a great deal of
the cooking and is charging in there
even more so now there is good and there
is bad certainly thing like the food
processor saran wrap and and
a plastic or at the rubber spatula after
Lee great innovation hopeful a 30 year
but beside this you know we always
manipulate food and our ancestor you
know didn't have anything to eat and
what we call wit now was actually a wild
wild weed you know which through
crossbreeding and challenging and
manipulation we end up now with this I
mean not that long ago gonna get a child
you could not each string bean before
string it on one side and the other side
which i try to do and I had to do a
couple of you know pound or whatever
that my mother wanted me to do my
brother and I try to cut the end of it
with a scissor to which of course those
beans were ability on a table so now
there is always been some manipulation
to make it better without the string or
to make the animal fatter or not as fat
or more tender or this and that so those
manipulation of existing all the time
now bioengineered food is something else
you know that we get into other area
which has to be controlled I am NOT by
definition opposed to anything because I
think that to fit the world we need that
type of improvement but it has to be
extremely controlled you know but
without any question if you can do an
egg which takes like an eggs and we are
grown and eggs and it has off half of
the amount of cholesterol why not you
know if you can have a tomato that
because of some manipulation doesn't
need to be sprayed with a sector side
and pesticide releasing being resistant
to this why not that may be a plus but
as I say you have to do it with
circumspection you really have to
control it you know it has charge it for
both you know worse and better I mean
everything is a thing finger tip of your
hand now you can get you know raspberry
from Peru in January when your I tell
you that they are as
when your palate doesn't believe it
because it's not the time of the year or
raspberry but it is true that now we
have and the process of Sylvie's for
example or other process of handling the
food will make it better and better so
that we can have fresher and better
product as as new innovation in
technology happen so this is a plus on
the other end it seemed that that
globalization have taken a great deal
out of out of any video and cooking out
of ethnicity out of expression and the
food would be or people would express
themselves with the food of their own
not only country but their own village
of their own small place in front where
they live you know and that us kind of
being damaged by this to a certain
extent I am a positive and I am Optimus
you know in life so I think that we are
moving to a better thing yet what we
have to do more than anything else is to
try to feed other people in the world we
have enough food in the world to feed
the whole world but it has to be
distributed it has to be taken there
without Lord in the Bandit you know in
African all that take hold of that food
and the bargain with it and while
children are dying